[Music]
welcome to ear biscuits the podcast
where two lifelong friends talk about
life for a long time i'm rhett and i'm
link this week at the round table of dim
lighting we're kicking off a new year
under the damn lighting
yeah you want to get it right you're
gonna say lightning lightning yeah gotta
lighten it up man
uh it's it's good to be back it's 20 22
man
so many twos
did you get your did you get your twenty
twenty two glasses
no
no i didn't yeah but your eye goes
through the uh
the hook of the second two are you
saying that you had something no i'm
just imagining what they look like well
i know because you told me that you were
alone
ringing in the new year yeah i was which
i'm sorry i was completely kind of
jealous completely alone i actually
think i was asleep
as 2021 turned to 2022. that's a story
for another time i'll explain why
how i ended up being alone during
new year's
actually not today well i'll i'll get to
it today but i'm gonna tell the full
story two podcasts oh
wow this is a double teaser because
today we're talking about what happened
over christmas break okay that's what
we're talking about yeah we have not
talked to each other about the things
that we've experienced
over the break that we need to uh
share with each other in podcast form
this is how we conduct our friendship i
don't know do we you know we it's always
up for debate whether or not we're going
to speak at all over a christmas break i
asked to borrow one wheel
yep and you weren't home and i said i
got a key yeah well i said is there a
garage code you said my garage has no
code i'm like what yeah and that was not
a riddle i said well i have a key to
your house i'm just going to use that
and i'd go over there
and
you would change all the locks yeah i
don't know how i was supposed to feel
about that you didn't ask i mean i
i went to three different doors my key
homie
uh and i couldn't get in first like it
was it was i'm pretty sure that your
wife has the correct key brought our
entire friendship into question it's
like i think your wife has the correct
key you're locking me out you do not i
do
she gave me the key
it was labeled and everything well it
recently got all the locks changed not
uh because something to keep the meals
out social security issue um
because it was one of those things where
we got a new doorknob a few years ago
and then you get one and then you're
like ah we got to get these locks
changed they all match at some point and
then
like three years later we finally made a
decision i guess you didn't get the memo
yeah hook me up with a key so i can just
get that one you can probably open up
one of those old door door locks
that's somewhere like a junkyard lando
was waiting in the car when i got back
to the car and said they changed the
locks they can't get in he said did you
try to just open the door they'd
probably just leave the house unlocked
uh no
we i mean we do when we're we're there i
mean i don't like lock myself yeah i was
like they're on vacation home vacation
their security is on lockdown cameras
are on so the meals were i mean we kind
of had inverted vacations and yes i do
think that's the only time we talked
that's healthy yeah yeah i didn't wish
you merry christmas
merry christmas merry christmas happy
new year happy new year here it is we
just did it see it's it's it's healthy
it's not knocking me out of your house
well
you know my christmas journey
starts before i even left to go back
home to north carolina because something
very significant happened to me and i
feel almost ashamed to admit this
uh but since i'm in good company when i
say what something i i've never done
before i'm sure i'll be supported in
that the mclaughlin i don't know what
you mean by that you'll understand in a
moment the mclaughlins had never
watched it's a wonderful life
none of us had what
you've never watched it's a wonderful
life and i and it's gonna seem a lot
less dramatic because i'm sure the neils
have never watched such a wonderful life
either
but i have heard of it yeah well okay so
we have a tradition in the mclaughlin
household uh yep james stewart actually
and he is credited at that point oh i
just made that note when i saw it on the
screen
the mclaughlins have a tradition of
watching the die hard series because it
it it is a christmas movie technically
at least the first one even though it
was released in july as i read
uh recently but it take it really was
what takes place over christmas yeah uh
was the third one which is die hard with
a vengeance it's got samuel l jackson in
it anyway we watched i've seen that one
it's the only one i've seen
it's like the only rocky you've seen is
rocky five
yeah
right
this is this is another another podcast
um
so we watched that
loved it
but then we wanted to watch another
christmas movie at some point before we
went back to north carolina and jesse
was like
what if we watch it's a wonderful life i
mean it's at the top like if you look up
lists of christmas movies that you
should watch it's always number one and
i'm always and i have a bias what
happened to your hand
i don't know thanks for noticing but i
think it's from
mountain biking i think i hit my hand on
some brush you know because your
your knuckles are out
knuckles out knuckles out man
uh i'm sorry
i just noticed it um
it's at the top of all you got to do is
give me a key to your house you don't
have to notice things about me you don't
have to apologize you don't have to wish
me merry christmas
all you got to do is give me a key to
your house man just talk about that talk
to my wife about that that's simple um
it's at the top of every list and so
but i have a bias against old movies as
i'm sure you do i know you do and many
other people do like everybody's like oh
you got to watch these classic movies
like when you look going right now i was
biased against movies apparently older
movies well like no but you pre-90s but
neither one of us are those people who
watch like old movies from the early
you know hollywood era right black and
white movies that kind of thing in the
classics like ones that i'm seeing some
kind of weird i'm having lots of
physical things happen i'm seeing like a
weird hair that i'm staring at and i'm
trying to get it
out of my face it's just your your it
might be one of my eyebrows turning into
like a
geology professor eyebrow i think i got
it um i
i didn't want to watch it because
because every time i make the decision
to watch an old movie i'm like the
pacing is horrible the acting is
horrible like this is before people even
knew how to make movies man right
but i'm like okay we'll watch just a
wonderful life and we'll get the kids to
watch it too it's especially horrible to
try to get your kids to watch old movies
because it's not hd they have even less
of an attention span than i do yeah
forget black and white it's not in high
definition
well it's down no that's not the issue
there's plenty definition because it was
film and they do the transfer at some
point did you watch the colorizer we're
not talking about vhs here
so i made the decision to watch the
colorized version oh i
um okay because i was like
and i was thinking about the kids at
this point because i was like
they have
a horrible attention span one of the
things you can do to your phone is like
turn all the icons to black and white if
you want to never look at your phone
again like there's some people who do
that you know so it doesn't entice you
it doesn't entice you i wanted to entice
the children yeah yeah yeah and so i
wanted to give them the colorized
version and it's very well done
colorized version but let me talk about
the movie for a second
i gotta say
in one failed swoop
this movie lodged itself in my top 10
movies of all time are you serious yes
what yeah
just because it was in color
did it surprise you that much jesse and
i kept leaning over to each other and
saying things like
this is well written like it just like i
did i just didn't it's well written you
know what i'm saying like it just was
and also yes it's jimmy stewart james
but and yes it's over the top in many
ways but also it was very compelling
there were some scenes where i was just
like this dude is this dude is a talent
jimmy stored his talent
spread the news um okay i think i have
seen to kill a mockingbird mockingbird
uh yeah it's been a while since i saw
that that was jimmy stewart right i
think so yeah um
i thought it was matthew mcconaughey
um i don't know what it is but i know
what you're talking about
lincoln lawyer no the one before that
yeah i think it was to kill a
mockingbird it was the it was the new
link
um
anyway i don't want to spend any more
time talking about it because you've
either seen it or you haven't seen it
but if you have i just got to say if you
haven't isn't it long though how long is
it three hours no no it's not it's
longer than i expected an old movie to
be i'd say two hours two hours and 20
minutes or something like that that's a
lot these days maybe just two hours i
don't know
um what did the kids say though were
they leaning over and saying it's well
written
the no they were they were okay locke is
the toughest critic he was really into
it and then it's like hour like minute
90 we started kind of losing him we kept
shepherd the whole time yeah right to
the end and i was weeping
multiple times
it doesn't take much for me to weep at a
movie
like a
ridiculous thing to say
but two these two guys have been
sleeping on it i'm still sleeping you
seen it
kiko's been sleeping on it too a lot of
people have been sleeping on it because
it's it's it's fake color man i mean
it's
over two hours watch the black and white
version so then i tell jenna jenna's not
here today but i tell jenna that i
finally watched it and first of all she
was offended that i had never watched it
before and and she loves all movies she
was like oh it's so good wow and then i
was like it actually made me and jesse
come to the same conclusion which is
we're going to start watching old movies
because you get so overwhelmed with all
the options that you have and then we're
thinking like let's just i'm going to go
to the list of the top 100 movies of all
time you got your
casablanca and you know and and
other ones
and so i'm talking to jenna and she says
oh
casablanca is my favorite movie of all
time that's that's the best movie ever
made
and so i'm like okay well did you watch
it already no i haven't but we are
planning on it okay i feel like i got a
you know when you when somebody you
discover a new television show like
everybody's like you never seen breaking
bad and you're like oh i've got this all
these seasons of breaking bad to go and
watch now i feel like i've got a whole
new season of breaking bad and it's just
old movies you're telling me that i
don't need to br alter my expectations
at all just watch it's a wonderful life
i don't think you're gonna like it
you i now you listening you're going to
like it link i'm not going to like it
you're so particular but i'm not
contrary i'm very i'm open no
you're i don't want to disprove you just
for the sake of it i don't i think that
you may be too distracted by some of the
conventions of of old filmmaking and but
i i just was like and also i see now i
have to like it in order to to to like
you don't like sentimental movies
okay you don't like sentimental movies
when you feel like you're being
emotionally manipulated by a movie you
have a you're offended by it i don't
know that that's true i when you go
through your top your top favorite
movies yeah it's not it's not
sentimental movies and so i'm
sentimental in real life sure yeah i
agree with that but you don't like
sentimental movies i love sentimental
movies and so
it you know i'm not saying it's just all
sentiment
but you may be like okay when you get to
the place where you're really supposed
to like have an emotional reaction to it
you may just be like i'm not on board
for this and if you're not then you're
not gonna say that it's good movie
but you should try it with your family
and if you all hate it don't tell
anybody that was like the worst
you should try it next year and in fact
everybody listening if you haven't
watched it
don't watch it now wait until next
christmas and you will have forgotten
how i built it up in fact make a
reminder don't say rhett said watch what
it's a wonderful like just say let's
watch a wonderful life put it as a
little reminder that pops up about a
week before christmas you won't remember
where this came from oh i wanted myself
to remind myself no you could say note
to self yeah you can say note to self
watch just a wonderful life with low
expectations because i went in with low
expectations note to future self you
know what
what could be
here's here's something a little more
pertinent
i mean i'm not going to call this
resolutions but
let's let's come up with some
notes to future self make those now and
and then
time release those throughout your year
yeah that's how resolution resolution
should be time released this is so
ironic you're known as smart this is
super smart i mean i hate to say
something then ask if it's smart it's
super ironic though because i literally
got one of these today
that i had written to myself uh-uh uh i
can't see when i wrote it but it was at
least a month ago
and it popped up as i was driving in i
saw it pop up on my phone i didn't have
i'm not looking at my phone it just
popped up
i'm a safe driver
it says
purchase a really is chorizo and santo
thomas rice
what yeah it was chorizo and rice it's
the spanish chorizo and the spanish rice
that i use in my paella but i'm trying
to say i'm trying to say that correctly
because so many people have told me that
i'm saying i'm saying paella which is
not it's paella
paella
there is a difference
it's not a yay
but but so i got was this a mistake or
did you did you remember that this is
when you wanted it to sprout it was i'm
going out of town i'm about to go out of
town because i made my paella for our
christmas dinner before we left for like
the family that's what shepard requested
and i was like oh i need to replenish
these main ingredients for this thing
but i don't want them to show up while
i'm out of town
and so i just was like i'll just make a
reminder to order this stuff when i get
back and boom there it is so i made a
note of my only note i made in my future
self 2022 stuff was to get rice and
chorizo you should just make a note to
your future self
right now say
to remind you just pick a random time of
year and just say make paella again
you're assuming that you've fallen out
of the routine of making it i'm not
going to need a reminder for that well
then something like that i guess trying
to capture the spirit of the idea lots
of requests from my paella including
from your wife okay
listen
i'm not trying
how could you be insulted by such a
creative idea
i mean i'm just so sensitive come up
with something else meaning to be
reminded to make my paella
listen that's it's your problem i'll do
it for me
i've been holding something back from
you
and it's
i got the most amazing christmas gift oh
really
yeah
and i've got it i've got video to
support it
and to bring it to life for you don't
look at don't look at my nose i'm not
looking i'm just i'm looking i'm just
i'm
just sort of like looking down don't
look down look up look up with hope why
is it so far out where's your phone so
far off
because that's where i want it
okay
we got important stuff to get to i just
told you that like i got the best gift
of my entire life of your entire life
potentially i i think it's it's yes
okay yes i think so i'm anxious to see
that
but i if you want a gift that is uh the
best gift you'll ever get in your entire
life you should get the
10-year anniversary mug which is this
season's
throwback but also celebrating 10 years
of gmm mug available dot com so it's got
the old logo on it it's got the old
color scheme with the black on the
outside the orange on the inside
and then the special ten years of
mythicality logo
that's got the wheel of mythicality
built into the zero on the 10 i mean
it's so nostalgic yeah the taste stuff
tastes good in it yeah it's like
drinking it's a wonderful life
color
in color
that's what it's like so get that thing
mythical.com
get your mug on
our
trips were kind of inverted i went
home first like i decided i was doing a
pre-christmas
visit back home
and
i want i kind of swung the pendulum from
last time i went home in july it was
like three weeks it was
that was quite it was it was way too
long to be anywhere no offense to my
family but like
you know you don't see each other that
often and then you see each other for
three weeks and it's like okay
so i was like we're just gonna do
we're gonna see everybody once everybody
gets a day and there's three different
entities
and you add a travel day on each end
five days total this is that's the most
efficient christmas trip that you can
imagine it's that i've ever taken
and is this the new norm for you it's
the it it was great i think our plan is
as long as we can go home another time
in the year like you know there's a
wedding we're going to go back for maybe
a second
event a second wedding you know somebody
getting married again or somebody
getting married to themselves again that
happens oh would you go home from one of
those i didn't know that was a thing no
like if your like brother-in-law was
like we're getting married again you
know people getting married as a second
time for themselves no to their spouse
oh i'm not talking about dennis
rodriguez so renew the vows i'm talking
yeah renewing of that yeah i know about
that well no what if your brother-in-law
wanted to marry himself like dennis
rodman would you go back home for that
definitely not
definitely not
i don't even think i was a bit video in
for that you know what i'm saying dennis
rodman did that man he put on a wedding
dress and he married himself
did he take it off and put it back on he
played both roles he was on fire in the
90s oh yeah he had his he had his moment
everybody had to watch him yeah yes it
was very efficient
and
it is it is the new norm subject to
being able to go back at other times
it's like it's better to have
more visits over the year
you know
subject to whatever happens
globally
um it was great
and it was before christmas so we got
home we flew back on christmas eve eve
so that then in our own home in our own
space we could have our own
christmas eve and christmas day
and then
uh i was pushing hard to then do
something after christmas because we had
another week kids were out of school for
another two weeks but i was out of work
for another week you got to work i'm not
out of work anymore i found i i found an
opportunity
uh everybody just wanted to stay at home
and do their own thing and not travel
and it's like well i can't really blame
you with
the omicron or whatever so let's just
let's just hang back at home
um but yeah it was
i'm really glad we made that decision
because the time was sweet and then you
you get out before it's too much
you know you end it before with people
wanting a little bit more well you did a
george costanza trip
by all accounts that's the way to do it
man i mean it was great one day per per
entity i mean i respect this choice when
we finally i don't think i could get
away with it i saw my i saw my mom we
saw christy's parents for like a little
bit on that on on on
an extra day so they each got like a day
and a half did you plan
did you feel
like okay we need to really
you didn't plan anything it's just like
we're just gonna be together so we can
just go and hang out at their house for
a day and this is the day that we have
yeah
and it's i mean it's you just plan them
what what's the approach to meals
i think that's the main thing
and we're always big on bojangles being
a part of that
because
christy's dad likes to cook a lot of
stuff but then if it's not at his house
he's coming up to um
christy's sister's house then it's like
he's got to bring a bunch of
paraphernalia and then he's like so
worried about cooking that like we're
not spending quality time together so we
wanted an emphasis on quality time and
bojangles well and we hit the bojangles
horde well
let me interject here because this is
one of my trip talking points
i do want to talk about bojangles at
length well my point is not just
bojangles my point is
and i you probably didn't experience
this in your this is another advantage
potentially of your five-day trip
i was there for longer than five days
i was probably there for like nine or
ten
and the food that you end up eating when
you are back home yeah there is a
cumulative effect
on all this
chicken and barbecue and just meat and
sugar and fat we're not used to it man
it is unreal so what i did i i
anticipated this because i just say
listen caution to the wind this is the
holidays and i and i have a certain
number of places that i like to go i
like to go to bojangles i like to make a
trip
to smithfield's chicken and barbecue i
ended up making two trips because i may
i always make a solo trip because my
family's not too into it because it's
such a genuine eastern north carolina
like yeah in fact i'm just gonna go
ahead and tell you this is my wreck
smithfield's chicken and barbecue
because well i can one-up it but go
ahead it's because it's the only if
you're if you're traveling through
north carolina yeah you're right and
you've never been in north carolina and
you want to know what north carolina
barbecue tastes like and you don't want
to go to like a sit-down restaurant
you're just like let me just get a
sandwich real quick in a drive-through
it's the only fast food place in america
that i'm aware of that if you order a
barbecue sandwich you will get
quintessential eastern north carolina
vinegar-based sauce and get it with the
slaw on the sandwich because you just
need to get the full even if you don't
think you like cabbage or salt you need
to get it that is the experience of what
people in the eastern part of north
carolina eat they also have something
called brunswick stew in my mind this is
the only fast food restaurant that
serves brunswick stew which is again
which again is a distinctly
north carolina thing it's got pork in it
it's a bunch of stuff and you know what
we got tomato based potato stew we think
pork we think that the meat in the smith
fields brunswick stew is chicken
not pork
we got into a little debate with my
mother-in-law there might be chicken in
it too and then she started saying
you're saying there's no pork in it well
i'm not gonna say that the brunswick
stew that she had growing up that was
made by her grandmother and her
great-grandmother they would put
squirrel
and possum
because it was the it was the st
everything stew that you could put all
this wild game and roadkill and [ __ ] in
right okay anyway smithfield's chicken
and barbecue i don't i'm not gonna say
that they roadkill well maybe they did i
don't think they did and i made the stop
by there i get the brunswick stew
they're not doing the buy one get one
free pints anymore because they realize
that they wised up that these yankees
moving in or gonna just buy it for six
dollars a pint and not ask any questions
about it yeah these yuppies
yankees i really like the shrimp there
uh did you there's this fried shrimp i
love the fried shrimp there um but the
the cumin and not just the stuff you're
eating at fast hush puppies we did
zak's bees my my family has migrated
a little bit away they do bojangles when
they're with their cousins
but
they they're really into the zaxby's of
it all because they like the wings and
the spicy yeah on on the wings but so
much fried chicken and then everything
you're eating at every meal that you're
being served is also this heavy food
because it's holiday food oh god yeah i
had i took a thing of fiber pills with
me
because i was like this is gonna screw
me up so bad i gotta have to keep it
moving have you tried these
do you take you still do the spoonful of
the fiber no
i i i put flax seed in my smoothie okay
i stopped doing the the the psyllium
husk as well but when traveling i have
found that you can you can get the
capsules that's the same thing and you
just take those they take like six or
seven of them c37 pills of fiber well if
you've got a high tolerance to that
stuff like i do because i've used it for
so long yeah uh that's i wouldn't
recommend that to the layman but to the
professional fighter no different than
just taking a scoop of it but it's like
so much easier and it's easier to travel
you got to drink a lot of water though
right because if you travel with that
bag of fiber it looks like you've got
like some bad coke
and then you have to like explain that
to the tsa i mean i would it looks more
like sawdust
i got some bad coke man
just a little bit brown i'm sorry i've
been shaving
i've been shaving some wood thinking
it's sniffable snortable anyway
so you you i agree with smithfields but
i mean if you're going to go full local
and you're in the sanford area which my
mom is um you got to get the ron's barn
baby oh you went to run we went to run
barn dang it would hush puppies she
brought it home so it's everything i
mean they don't have brunswick stew that
i know of but every time my mom goes in
there they're like tell link to come in
oh man ron's barney they know they know
me there is there's still one in coats
they know you too no
pope's barn in in uh
post bar it changed iran's barn and then
i think they closed that one but they're
still ron is still going in sanford oh
yeah that's worth a trip and their
shrimp is great there that's my main
thing there
but back to bojangles the thing that i
had been i'd forgotten in july i was
like i'm not going to make this mistake
again
i'm going to get that bojangles chicken
sandwich
i got to try this thing
you know because
you know our friends back home been
talking it up right our friend harm was
saying it's the best one out of all the
chicken sandwiches all of them yeah i'm
like how could that be have you had it
no
it's fabulous
but
oh it's not
i mean i
chick-fil-a chicken sandwich is still
the top of my list above the popeye's
sandwich
um
even the zaxby sandwich which i did have
back in july i don't get the zaxby
sandwich i get the wings zaxby sandwich
is good the bojangle sandwich is better
but it's it's it's much better than the
previous bojangles chicken sandwich it's
it's bigger it's crispier
but
it's just that there's no spicy sauce on
it it's just mayo
because the chicken itself is supposed
to be spicy just like all the other how
is it different than the than the
chicken sandwich that they had before
it's bigger and
crunchier
it's very good
okay i'll put it in my top
i'll tie it with popeyes even though
it's not as big or as crunchy as popeyes
hmm oh i've got a great chicken story i
don't have to wait i have to tell you
gosh i got it i can't tell you this
because it doesn't fit in this one i got
to get
i got to get to
my gift because this happened
like two days before
we leave to go home
my aunt tc sends me a text and she says
remember this
now
uh a few
over the past few podcasts
in at the end of the year we talked
about like our best gift ever
and
do you remember what
the best your trip that i ever got my
truck when i was 15 and a half my popeye
surprised me they gave me accepted so
she sends me a picture and it's the
picture
of my truck a current picture a current
picture of my truck you see where this
is going
so i said if you have your truck well if
if uncle
so and then i started piecing it
together and my nana's brother
my uncle ross who you know
um
he he recently passed away and they were
having an estate sale yeah and my aunt
tc was at the freaking estate sale and
she snapped a picture of
my truck but she didn't snap it up and
buy it for you and i said yeah remember
that truck i was actually talking about
it as like the most meaningful gift i've
ever gotten in my life on a recent
episode of our podcast
uh it's at uncle ross's right it's still
there like i knew a couple of years ago
i went home for christmas and i i heard
that it was there and i went and saw it
i visited with my truck
i think i told you that the keys weren't
in it and i sat in the truck
and just kind of
memories just flooded back
and then i got out of the truck and i
came back home and forgot about it and
yeah so
he passes away they're selling the thing
and i was like i'll buy it
christy was like you should buy it and
then i was like i'll buy it yeah i mean
i assume a 1987
nissan pickup truck is not gonna go for
more than let's just say uh
you paid
thirteen hundred dollars for it
i don't wanna say what i paid for it
because it's like uh i said whatever
they wanna whatever price that the
family's putting more than 1300
i did
i was like you know what for me
i'm not whatever they want
what ask for it i'll pay for it it's not
going to be they should be 4 000.
it wasn't that much okay they said 3 500
will do it 3 000.
what you making me say
okay it was 3 000. um and i was like you
know what i'll i'll i'll do it and you
know as i'm telling the story i'm
remembering that i still haven't paid
for it so i've got to arrange to have
money give yourself a future reminder so
at some point in 2022 you should pay for
that truck so
um
yeah it was like totally out of
character for me but i was like i have
to do this
i have to
re-gift myself my favorite gift that
i've gotten 28 years
after the fact
giving myself the same gift that i got
28 i was given 28 years earlier that i
was talking about is my most meaningful
gift i've ever gotten
you put it on a truck bed and put it out
here i say you know what i'll just drive
it to my mom's house and then i can
teach the kids how to drive stick using
this thing and it'll be at my mom's
house under the shelter whenever i go
home and visit
we'll just you know she'll crank it up
occasionally and i'll just have it so i
want to show you like i said i've got a
a video journey i want to take you on
here right
there it is
oh wow he took such good care of it
yeah now the wheels have been made
smaller because the wheels you had were
too big
you think they were bigger than they
really were those aren't the same wheels
are they the same wheels no look how
small it is you look a giant
they don't make trucks this small i know
it's crazy isn't it 28 years later it's
like a golf cart i got it again
1987 nissan pickup
same grille same chrome bumper
different rims
similar rims the wheels are the same
size you kind of doing this like
a bad youtuber
like a youtuber who hasn't learned
how to make a video this is dynamic
first thing i noticed is that in order
to get in the well the handle's broke
the handle is missing you're going to
grab this
edge here that's easy
like it's uh
how many miles on that thing a different
seat
it says 200 000 but it's a new motor
a newer motor
the whole bench is new though whole
bench is new gear shift different radio
i think they put an ac in it at some
point don't you remember this thing
you didn't have ac
and
um
i remember that door with those those
panels on it like that so
so you can't close the door from the
inside you got to close it from the
outside because the handle's broken off
on the inside you shut in
character
yeah
okay
i mean we're gonna crank this puppy up
[Music]
okay
ho ho ho there we go
making some cod noises so she's got a
new motor
she smells like a tractor
smells horrible
because he was just using it at the farm
the memories in this thing
from when i was 15 and a half
learned how to drive
i'm gonna teach you how to drive a stick
just like i learned in this thing
[Music]
i didn't want to tell him about all the
makeout sessions
there's not a lot you can do besides i
mean
you can't do more than make out in that
you couldn't have intercourse in the cab
of that i could just i didn't it's well
because you're like religious
convictions but it's too small right
okay the michelin man drives a truck
you have a jacket like that
but yeah but yours is shiny
i mean i like it i like the jacket belt
michelin
there is a speedometer but there is no
speedometer needle anymore yeah who
needs that it's like it would be right
here
so you're not gonna be able to tell how
fast does that does the knob turn it off
right now we're going zero
[Music]
it's been a while since you drove a
stick huh it's very finicky
yeah it's not like the new ones where
you basically can't stall out
the cl those old clutches were
more gas and more gas
yeah temperamental i'm starting to teach
he's learning it definitely picking up
on all this
the window thing fell off again
do you remember i couldn't roll down my
passenger window because the whole the
glass would fall down into the door
i got it
28 years later this thing is still
trucking man it's kind of crazy
i mean nissan well built nissan
[Applause]
look at how much fun i'm having yeah i
mean i hear with the woos and everything
the stuff we did in that truck too the
damage that you inflicted on that thing
you getting the hang of this
sure that's not how you learn how to
drive a stick by watching someone else
do it that's just not hey oh it just
knocked off check it out
so then all right
i think i got
everywhere the truck goes life follows
i was kind of having my own fun
and then just remind you all the times i
drove up to your house and you get in
and then we drive off into the
woods on the like farmer's land and like
like get stuck in ditches well this
looks like a video we would have made
like the day you got your truck if we
had the capability of doing that yeah
i'm gonna drive through the yard
i'm gonna do a loop through the yard so
i think i i eventually let lincoln drive
it if you get it on the first try
you win
a lot of respect but don't worry it's
not going to happen
first
this is tough because lincoln i think is
aware that i'm going to be showing this
to
a lot of pressure
give it a little gas ease off the clutch
right there stop on the clutch and just
you got to feel that spot where it's
about to catch now a little more gas a
little more gas more gas more gas more
gas
off the clutch
more gas more gas
more gap
[Laughter]
it's hard
all right
i'll give it a go i'll let him
experience some victory here
a little bit of gas it's okay for you to
be coasting that makes it easier
i'm a pretty good instructor more gas
more gas more gas more gas more gas more
yeah
more gas more getting more gas got it
[Music]
yeah blow the blow
look at that see the moment that my
granddad shared with me
i've now passed along to my own freaking
son that's beautiful now what did he how
did it end i said i'm gonna do the same
thing with my daughter
she's just a michelin woman
oh yeah she did it now keep going you
can first try it second
he's unfazed
she went to college right right she's
been educated higher education speed up
more you got to you got to be going
faster
i think i could be a driving instructor
that seems like something you'd want to
do speed up a little bit you go
go on this straight away and then you
can try to put it
you would love to be a driving
instructor because you would get your
own steering wheel on your side oh yeah
you know
it's like a control freak stream i don't
think they do that anymore they don't
they don't make those
anymore yes i think um yeah so lily got
to learn how to drive well i gotta say
i'm i'm jealous for multiple reasons i
you know i i'm i'm jealous because
that's cool picture i'm jealous because
you know how before how about that
picture that's equally cool you don't
have to show low angle you don't have to
show me there's another one
and then
no there's a there's a selfie yeah
that's a bad one
and then there's a vertical cell phone
you can't hardly see the truck what
about that um and then okay that's it
before
the break
i was talking to you about how my wife
was saying that she was going to give me
the best gift that's right that she has
ever given me yeah if there's no way it
could top this
well she hasn't given it to me yet i
don't know what i was gonna ask she
hasn't given it to you there was a
complication with it well you know what
christy and lily have been building up
this gift that didn't come from me it's
still not here you know supply chains
but nothing's gonna top the truck i
think it's the same thing no it could be
the same thing because
our guess was that it was a dog
it was not i mean and jesse confirmed it
was not a dog however
we are we are 20 22 is the year of the
dog for us the year of the second dog
for us good but that i highly recommend
it but i still don't know what it is
i
i mean i'm just like you tell me when
you get it you tell me what it is and
when i get mine i'll tell you what it is
okay yeah
hold on
how's that for a deal
and and with the way the supply chains
are it may be next christmas
who knows but anytime you want to come
over to my mom's house and drive that
truck it's very tempting i'm thinking
about setting a reminder right now it
it's it was so small
when you get back in it
it's like i can't believe you even fit
in the thing
you're like you had to be hunched over
oh i wasn't comfortable by any means i
was definitely making a sacrifice as
your friend and i was telling lincoln
you know it's like that right here in
the middle is where i would put my
portable cd player and hook it up to the
cassette adapter oh yeah and then every
time i go over a bump it would it would
skip because it didn't have enough of a
buffer but you can get you but you can
get the non-skippable one like the
really good sony one yeah um
so i that that is the defining moment of
my
christmas back home
if i were to pinpoint so you gonna just
keep it forever
yeah why not well you can because you
could probably only get 1300 bucks if
you try to sell it right
if maybe
it's definitely it's not worth more to
anybody else than it is
that's definitely true
so yeah what if one day
lincoln's teaching
his kids or or lily i guess she could
also do it
they both have the capabilities now to
drive a stick i've passed that on and
then they can pass it on maybe in the
same truck but potentially i mean you're
gonna have to really keep that thing on
lockdown if you wanna yeah them to be
able to teach their kids about it yeah
um did you go back through fuquay any i
skirted fuquay fuquay is
i mean it just continues to grow i've
heard about there's a whole new facility
like a high rise there's a high i mean i
would call it a high rise it may be only
three stories downtown fuquay yeah just
literally blocks maybe five story i
don't know from where our studio used to
be so i went to the old studio i got a
little pic oh yeah okay a little selfie
in front it's a hair salon right it's a
hair salon on one side and a church
office on the other side all right good
we just did the whole we took both sides
when we did it that's right big business
uh i went by there i like how they're
doing
the lord's work which is uh the hair
cutting yeah
um
there's two like good coffee shops in
fuquay now there's you know there's
stick boy there's well i guess three
because the stick boy is a great bakery
also does coffee there's the mill which
is like the new like
it's new to me bigger one across the
street which is literally across the
street from our old studio like we if we
had a stuck around we would have had a
coffee shop that we could have just
thrown a stick at oh damn and then we
could have been stoning a coffee shop on
the next block
south
or east
across the main road there's another
coffee shop now on that next block how
could how how can
the clientele support three coffee shops
fuqua's got
tens of thousands of people man let me
tell you right and they're making it to
the south side they got this high-rise
is it really a high-rise
it's a it is a i mean it's like set it's
it's a con condominiums retail and
parking it doesn't fit does it i heard
it doesn't fit well i can understand why
people would say that because it
definitely does not it's
it's bigger than everything else around
it
it's also a sign of the times man it's
like fuquay's on the up and up do you
think if we would have stayed in fuquay
and somehow experienced like the north
carolina
equivalent of the success we've had out
here do you think we would be the ones
building that high rise well no because
we're not real estate developers we're
comedians
that's true i mean i think we could have
gotten a piece of the action maybe we
would be yeah we may be investors yeah
but the other thing that's happening if
you quake which
is a little bit of a mind screw is
ashworth's is still there
for old men the
traffic and traffic is bad
traffic
is more debilitating than la traffic
because
la traffic comes with an expectation of
traffic it's like yes i'm in this place
that it costs so much to live and
there's so many people and and but
you're on this road like man five two
roads yeah but if you quite there's they
can't do anything especially when you're
coming down
sun is at sunset lake you're coming down
and you're trying to get into town we
are now having a local podcast
like this is the if we stay in north
carolina this is what this is what the
podcast would be that's a good idea
maybe we move back and we just do that
like just do little news around fuquay
complaining about traffic in fuquay
this is no but my parents had been
complaining about the traffic and i was
like you experienced and i was like i
don't under you don't know what traffic
is i mean they lived they lived out here
you know when i was younger it's bad huh
you can get stuck i got stuck
on that road
i was up there near like miss
slaughter's old house
okay yeah
you were you were trying to get to
smithville
yes
you were frustrated i had to wait
forever to get to smithfield i don't
understand what was happening oh yeah
they got to do some traffic engineering
there but if you quit
really really things are looking up they
need to put a subway system in um
my whole trip was defined by
uh my plans being thwarted right so
plan a for our trip was
we go back home to north carolina just
in time for jesse's birthday we have a
birthday celebration with her family and
my family all together
and
then we spend christmas
with our families and then the day after
christmas we hop on a plane hop on a
plane back and we fly to
mexico to have a wonderful time as a
family just the four of us right i was
like damn they're going to mexico we're
just going to be sitting on our butts
and spend a week in mexico
through the new year and then come back
now
as we all know um
omicron was
was making itself known to our to our
world and country
and so things began to get a little bit
dicey dicey and and let me i just i
don't want to i've done enough of my
covid rants and you talked about
vaccines and all that you know where i
stand on all that
because i'm not i'm not going to do that
what i will say is that
this has been going on for so long
for the way that i have kind of
processed this is like i'm like listen
i'm vaccinated
and i and especially with this latest
strain which basically everyone who
knows anything is saying
this thing is so contagious that you
will you are going to be exposed to it
right you're gonna what you're either
gonna get exposed to with the vaccine or
without the vaccine and
you can take all kinds of precautions
and do all the social distancing and the
masking and all that which i continue to
do yeah
uh but you're gonna get exposed to it
but you're boosted you said vaccinated
but you're yeah
i'm also boosted that's it's important
differentiation yeah it is uh it is in
terms of lowering the chances of getting
infected it in terms of whether you're
going to get severe illness the double
vax is
good for that now
but one of the things that
i had to do just to mentally make it
because first of all i recognize we live
in a very particular place out here on
the left coast in uh in los angeles yeah
where everybody pretty much
takes the pandemic very seriously and
takes all the precautions and does
everything this is a very unique place
there's a few places major cities around
the nation where that's the case but
like once you kind of get out of that
bubble people just don't care that much
right and so i knew i'm going into
environments where
people don't see this the same way that
i do
and so i and i just had to be like
listen i'm
vaccinated and boosted i'm going to take
precautions but i cannot constantly
worry about this i will not be able to
make it through this time if i'm worried
about me getting covered personally at
this point i'm honestly not worried
based on what we're seeing when people
who are vaccinated get it so that's why
you're like we're going to go with it
ahead with this trip yeah but what i'm
also so the thing the main anxiety that
i'm experiencing is not about me or any
of my family members getting covered
it's
the plans being thwarted the flight
being cancelled
getting in mexico it's like so it's you
can fly to mexico without
any sort of negative test but you can't
fly back into the u.s without getting a
negative test 24 hours prior to your
arrival or your flight
the place we were going to stay provided
tests and everything but i'm like we got
things to get back to and so i i'm
worried about our flight getting
canceled because every day there's more
flights getting canceled as we get
closer and closer to this time also i'm
worried about getting stuck in mexico
and thinking about what am i going to do
if we have to stay extra time in mexico
how am i going to stay an extra week am
i going to like what if it's one of my
kids am i going to be like uh we i have
to stay here because one of my kids has
tested positive
again it wasn't the fear of the illness
it was a fear of the
logical
or the the logistical implications of
somebody getting it yeah and jesse was
jessie was saying the whole time she was
like i don't i think we should cancel
the trip because you're going to be too
anxious and you're not going to be able
to enjoy yourself because you're going
to be worried about us getting stuck
this is the logistical stuff is the kind
of thing that i have i get anxiety about
and so i was like well you're not wrong
but let's do we're doing this you know
it's not really any less safe there than
it is here and like this stay committed
to the plan
and then
my brother test positive for kovy which
was happening
so many if you don't know somebody who
tested positive for covet in the past
couple of weeks then i don't know who
you are and where you live but like it's
it's happening everywhere
and of course i had spent
i had been with my brother at dinner
went to his house sat on a couch next to
him like
i just basically just been breathing the
same air
with him just multiple days in a row you
were doing that thing to each other
where it's like did my breath stink
and then he was like does my breath
stink yeah and then you're like
yes but does mine stink more yeah
exactly and then breathing each other's
air and then an hour later you do it all
again right what about now does my
wrestling and it was happening with
every family member did your breath
think and and so okay listen i don't
know
i ended up getting
all five symptoms of of omicron
like the ones that were listed as the
five most common symptoms i got all five
symptoms very mildly like to the point
where i was like is this an allergy is
this like a cold is this i tested
two times with one of those rapid tests
it was both negative everybody kept
saying that's negative these net the
negative tests are much less reliable
with this in general and also with this
strain and then when i got back i got a
pcr test
still negative so this is funny because
you're doing like it's like i mean
because there's this there's still this
stigma it's like yeah you leaned away
from me when it's like when people trust
me you've been exposed to coven i'm just
playing it up but when people say they
they've got it
there's still there's an eroding but
still present stigma of like i gotta
confess i got it
i got it well you know but that's i
think that's going away but you're doing
the opposite you're like trying to
convince me that you have it no well
here's first of all again i i did have
it man i'm not really thinking about the
widespread implications of the things
that i'm saying right now so please let
me speak freely
uh
but there's honestly there was a part of
me that was like i want to get this to
get it over with because i'm so tired of
worrying about it and everybody that i
know that's double backs that's getting
it is having such mild symptoms and i'm
like just give me the damn virus so i
can get through this and not have to
think about it anymore so you do feel
right or wrong that's what i was feeling
and so you
you're airing
you're leaning towards concluding my
brother
but you're leaning towards concluding
that you had it because that gives you
peace of mind no i
no i'm saying that
i had all the symptoms
as i'm and all these people online are
like these are the symptoms that i had
i'm not testing
net positive
and so i'm just like okay maybe i had it
maybe i didn't i'm not behaving any
differently than i was already i'm
taking all the precautions that we're
doing here we're not going to make no
no because i tested negative and i was
like if i test negative and these
symptoms are gone by the time we're
supposed to fly i'm going you felt that
was the part about going yeah
then shepherd
who is vaccinated not boosted
because he's only 13.
um
shepherd comes down with the exact same
symptoms as my brother which is
basically like a pretty
bad sore throat and like some aches and
what they was what you typically see in
a vaccinated person who gets it which is
just sort of a rough cold that kind of
knocks you out for a couple of days
and
uh and so again we tested him it was
negative but at that point it was
christmas eve
eve
when that happened with shepard and i
was like okay let's do it let's cancel
thankfully we got our money back for
everything like we didn't we actually
didn't have our trip insured i thought
that maybe it was but it wasn't
and so
thank you jenna for
making lots of phone calls and figuring
that out but
we got our money back so we didn't have
to pay anything
and and
and then there was sort of a sense of
relief but then i was like well what are
we going to do now we're just going to
stay in north carolina
because we were it was
the way that coveted impacted our family
gatherings was okay shepherd's not
coming over to
christmas eve at my parents
you know because they're in like their
mid
70s and yeah it's it's like we're trying
to protect everybody right and so deja
vu and so yeah i was like oh man this
again we have to do this and like cole
my brother couldn't come to the things i
saw him in the beginning of the trip and
i didn't see him again that sucks and so
i was just very frustrated by the whole
thing but i was also like i don't want
to stick around and be in this in this
situation where and again we're in a
place where some people are like
think that we're crazy right and it's
funny because when i would when somebody
would ask us to do something like
through my in-laws or through my parents
and they would be like do you all want
to go do this
i would literally say this i would say
you just tell them that we're crazy
liberals from california and we're
scared of the virus that will end the
conversation so we don't have to you can
put it on me because that's what people
think about me anyway so just say that
and that's why we're not going to your
dinner that you've got planned or
whatever we're crazy liberals and we're
scared of the virus
and so
that would just i had to kind of deploy
that strategy a couple of times because
i didn't work
yeah well i just ended the conversation
because i don't want to get into this
like yeah you see it this way i see it
this way let's have an argument about it
like it's like no you do your thing i'll
do my thing we're good
um
but i was like i want to make something
out of this trip right
i don't even know where i got the idea
but i was like just say i gave it to you
well you didn't um
cross country trip
me and lock
now lock and i've been trying to go to
multiple places together over the past
couple of years but it's been thwarted
by covid so we were like let's have a
covid family christmas and just go
straight across america
on a road trip brilliant idea um to get
back to la because when else are you
gonna have the time
and so
that is what we did and i and we
experienced a whole lot that i will talk
about in an exclusive episode of ear
biscuits oh wow not next week but the
following week i'm going to do i got
video i got pictures i got stories
to
share it on cindy lope or psoriasis
podcast i know well i mean i you'll get
the leftovers cindy gets the best
um but we had an incredible we that's i
feel like i saved christmas
when i heard through the grapevine that
you were traveling across the country i
had to break the text seal and and and
ask you about it because i was intrigued
i was jealous i was like man this is
better than mexico you know what i think
it ended up being better than me
you know a father-son thing it you've
got shepherd six so he could he he
wasn't eligible to come on this road
yeah and it was again locking our it's
locke's senior year in high school like
yeah and we're planning on getting
something for us
but it's like what's gonna happen with
spring break i don't know it's
impossible to make plans now but you
know what i can get in a damn car and
drive across america nobody can tell me
i can't do that right don't we need a
test to do that just go cross the
borders yeah so that's what we did well
i look forward to hearing about that i
mean the other thing that we're in the
midst of now is
celebrating 10 years of good myth good
morning it's happening on the good
mythical morning
channel all this week
and
so next week
we're going to push your road trip thing
to week after night so that we can while
we're still in the
the festive mode of celebrating
10 freaking years
of good mythical morning uh we'll talk
about that next week and you've already
given your wreck smithfield's chicken
and barbecue s-c-n-b they say on the
sign sometimes yeah i used to say
smithfield's really big and it does now
again oh good but if you get the cup
it says on one side okay smithfield's in
cursive on the other side it says scnb
they're like really trying to
keep that alive i feel like we should be
doing some sort of deal with them like
we should be like
the sonic guys for smithfields
but in the meantime
ron's barn there's only one
yeah all right if you can't make it to
ron's bar and go to smithfield's chicken
and barbers yeah that i like an
authentic north carolina barbecue
experience get the brunswick stew as
well we made it man we're in the new
year
we're pressing forward and it's gonna be
it's gonna be a good one
i choose to believe that this is gonna
be a great
year
hashtag your biscuits
holla at you boys
to watch more ear biscuits click on the
playlist on the right to watch the
previous episode of your biscuits click
on the playlist to the left and don't
forget to click on the circular icon to
subscribe if you prefer to listen to
this podcast it's available on all your
favorite podcast platforms thanks for
being your mythical best
[Music]